Salve lei è la mamma di Ah Mohamed Che
bel nome esotico Cerca Ma dove siete
arrivati di bello in vacanza Ah in
Marocco potevate restare lì No No dico
Visto che è così bello il Marocco
potevate rimanere un po' di più ah la
scuola certo ha ragione io razzista ma
no ma ci mancherebbe il Signore Maria
piccole dosi se riuscite a integrarvi e
siete tante persone piacevoli Il
problema è che la maggior parte di voi
non ha voglia di lavorare e allora ho
finito per fare i delinquenti e così no
eh non funziona così ha sentito la
novità cioè un nuovo bambino Eh sì è
figlio di due padri lo so sembra una
battuta ma invece tutto vero io Guardi
non ho niente assolutamente niente
contro i gay anzi tantissimi amici
omosessuali però ecco due padri non si
può sentire la famiglia è uno sola e
padre madre ce lo vengono su tutti
deviati drogati alcolizzati che cosa
stai insegnando scusi Sì sono divorziate
loro i miei figli hanno due padri
diversi Ma io a differenza di altre
mamme preferisco la mancanza di un padre
con una carta che si prende cura di loro
verranno su tutt'altro che deviati
glielo assicuro scusi ma con questi
permettimi signore che mi abbiate like
che si fuma le canne ma lei è impazzita
Ginevra Hai sentito Dimmi che non sei
diventato una deviata pure tu